cela dépend un peu de la situation dans
laquelle il se trouve
personnellement je m'inquiète beaucoup
pour les familles surtout les familles
nombreuses avec des enfants qui vivent
dans de petites appartement je pense que
c'est très difficile sur les station
spatiale internationale je parle de
grandes stations
nous avons beaucoup d espace donc ce
n'est pas si difficile mais je peux
imaginer des gens qui sont actuellement
obligés de rester dans de petits
appartements pendant toute la journée
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 pendant
des semaines car cette situation va peut
être durer pendant longtemps c'est très
difficile je pense qu'il ya certaines
stratégies que les gens peuvent employer
pour faire face à cela et pour s'aider
les uns les autres
je pense que la chose numéro une la plus
importante c'est de communiquer beaucoup
avec les autres on doit accepter que
quand on vit ensemble dans de petits
appartements va s'énerver
chacun va faire quelque chose qui va
déranger vraiment une autre personne